GOOD POINT.
>> Sean: GREAT.
TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT JOE BIDEN YOUR PRESIDENT
THINKS THERE IS NO INFLATION AND
NO BORDER CRISIS AND SAID HE
WOULD SEND U.S. TROOPS TO DEFEND
TAIWAN AGAINST THE CHINESE AND
HIS TEAM CORRECTED HIS RECORD.
JOE SAID THE PROOF OF THE
PUDDING IS IN THE EATING.
WATCH ME.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING.
ALSO VIRGINIA GOVERNOR GLENN
YOUNGKIN WILL BE HERE WITH HIS
PLAN TO RESTORE PARENTAL RIGHTS
IN EDUCATION.
THE WOKE LEFT WON'T LIKE IT AND
A MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
IT'S BIG.
AND WE BEGIN WITH FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS WHO WILL
JOIN US IN A MOMENT.
HE SENT ALL OF THE LIBERALS INTO
A FIT OF HYSTERIA.
DESANTIS RELOCATED HOMELESS AND
HUNGRY MIGRANTS AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH FOOD AND LODGING AND THOSE
WHO VOLUNTEERED, THEY FLEW NORTH
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
A COMMUNITY THAT CLAIMS TO BE
WELCOMING AND INCLUSIVE.
LAST WEEK WE SHOWED YOU THE
SIGNS ALL OVER THE ISLAND.
IT READS WE STAND WITH REFUGEES.
WELL, THE WEALTHY DEMOCRATS ARE
NOT WELCOMING AND BASED ON THEIR
DEFINITION OF RACISM, THEY ARE
BOTH ON STEROIDS.
THE 50 ILLEGALS WERE KICKED OUT
THE NEXT DAY.
THEY CALLED IN THE MILITARY AND
HAD EVERY SINGLE ONE EVER THEM
REMOVED FROM THE ISLAND.
ALL WHILE PATTING THEMSELVES ON
THE BACK FOR GIVING THEM ONE HOT
MEAL AND LETTING THEM STAY ONE
NIGHT.
THEY SAID THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CARE FOR THESE NEW
GUESTS DESPITE SCORES OF VACANT
HOTEL ROOMS.
AND THE THOUSANDS OF UNUSED
BEDROOMS IN THE EMPTY VACATION
HOMES INCLUDING OBAMA'S 7,000
SQUARE FOOT ESTATE.
WHY NOT OFFER 15 OF THE THIRD
ACRES TO HOUSE THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
THE MEDIA MOB, THE RACIST
LIBERALS ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD
ARE NOT THE VILLAINS.
NEITHER IS JOE BIDEN OR KAMALA
HARRIS.
EITHER ARE THE SANCTUARY CITIES
AND STATES.
THEY DO NOTHING TO ADOMIDATE
THEM.
-- ACCOMMODATE THEM.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS IS THE
VILLIAN.
AOC ACCUSED DESANTIS OF CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY.
AND HE CALLED RON DESANTIS
MORALLY REPREHENSIBLE AND NEWSOM
FORGOT ABOUT HIS OWN BUSSING
PROGRAM AS MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHEN HE SHIPPED
HOMELESS PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE MAD RON DESANTIS
LOCATED THEM TO THEIR PLUSH
COMMUNITY AND MAD THAT TEXAS'S
GOVERNOR IS LOCATING IMMIGRANTS
TO OUTSIDE OF KAMALA HARRIS'S
MANSION IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
IN A TWEET FROM NBC NEWS ONE
ACTIVIST SAID:
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS SAID NEW YORK
CITY IS OVERWHELMED WITH 2,000
MIGRANTS BUT EL PASO GETS 2,000
A DAY.
MAYOR LAURIE LIGHTFOOT IS
BEGGIN
BEGGING PEOPLE TO HELP WITH THE
IMMIGRANTS.
SHE IS BUSSING THE PEOPLE OUT OF
THE CITY AND THAT MEANS THEY
WILL BE SAFETY.
AND WASHINGTON, D.C. MAYOR
BOWSER DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND CALLED IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND DEMANDS
$50-MILLION FROM JOE BIDEN AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE NOT A BORDER TOWN.
WE DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO HANDLE THIS TYPE OF LEVEL OF
IMMIGRATION TO OUR CITY.
WE WILL CREATE A NEW NORMAL HERE
IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVE
A HUMANE WELCOME FOR PEOPLE AND
EFFICIENT SERVICE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
WE ARE NOT TEXAS.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO THE GREAT
MAYOR BUDGET OF $20 BILLION THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
HANDLE A COUPLE OF THOUSANDS OF
MIGRANTS.
EL PASO 2000 A DAY AND EAGLE
PASS IN TEXAS, HOME TO 30,000.
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO BEAR THE
BURDEN OF THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS
A DAY?
HOW IS THIS COMPASSIONATE
LIBERALISM AND IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
LAST WEEK GOVERNOR DESANTIS
EXPOSED THE HYPOCRISY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS BUT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE SECURITY CRISIS THAT
PRESENTED BY A WIDE OPEN BORDER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN OUR MIDDLE SON BRANDON
LEFT TO GO TO WORK, HE WAS ONLY
21 YEARS OLD.
THE LAST WORDS I SAID TO HIM WAS
I LOVE YOU.
AN ILLEGAL RAN INTO HIM AND HIT
HIM SO HARD HE CAUSED BRANDON'S
CAR TO FLIP AND KILLED HIM.
WE MET IT GOVERNOR DESANTIS.
HE SAID I WANT TO HEAR YOUR
SON'S STORY.
TO SEE THE COMPASSION IN HIS
EYES.
I SAW THE CONCERN.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE OTHER
LIVES WERE PROTECTED.
AS A GOVERNOR HE HAS BEEN
UPHOLDING THE OATH HE TOOK,